ah so bruce has a good question here
nicole does too um who is aristotle's
audience now that is a very interesting
question
because
we're not quite sure
um presumably his students right this is
uh the nikka mccann ethics nicomachus
was you know aristotle's son maybe it's
you know devoted to him in some way
um
certainly you can say this
we are not aristotle's audience
aristotle i don't think would have had
in mind people
23
hundred plus years in the future
non-greeks reading his stuff in
translation right but we're going to do
it anyway and the vast bulk of
aristotle's audience has always been
people he would have considered
barbarians and
um
you know maybe not fit for philosophy
there's a lot
to unpack there nicole
nicole says how were stoics different
from aristotelian ethics why were they
rivals well every school was a rival to
another school so trivially
if you weren't belonging to a school you
were a rival of that school if you
belong to another um the stoics think
that virtues um
you know are understood a bit
differently than aristotle we're going
to talk about the the mean the stoics
did not think that
virtues are actually a mean state
seneca kind of fudges a little bit on
that but the the
other stoics
agree on that they also don't have the
same exact organization and listing
as the aristotelians do
aristotle's we're going to see just
treats a number of different virtues and
vices
as
needing you know their own distinct
study the stoics lump them all under
what we call the cardinal virtues as did
the plaintiffs and the epicureans
where you have uh wisdom or prudence
temperance or self-control courage and
justice as like the main virtues
aristotle
treats all of those but he also thinks
we need to
you know veer off into
things like um
good humor or control of anger and the
stoics here's another thing that'll come
up like in in our third session
um the stoics thought that um
anger is always bad the aristotelians
thought that anger can sometimes be
good
steve has a question here how confident
our historians the texts we have today
are pretty close to what aristotle wrote
very confident um
there's there's really no reason to
doubt that you know what we've got are
essentially
manuscripts that have come down to us
through numerous sources
and um you know you can actually get
like a
you know for example and if you have a
critical edition
like this one you see these footnotes
that reference like you know this
manuscript uh variation you know we're
we're very confident about that
um
we know that we don't have a significant
portion of what aristotle wrote he
and his students you know for example
did studies of over 200 different greek
city-states constitutions
we have won
the constitution of athens we know that
there's other texts that he wrote that
we we don't have
um because we find them in in listings
so yeah good question
the question about um can virtue be
taught
now that
which is being discussed in the amino
that's very important and we're going to
get to that a little bit later i mean
i'll say this
aristotle
is
here's how aristotle is is a good bit
different from not just plato but also
the stoics
on these sorts of matters
he tends to be much more focused on
uh acting in certain ways
and
you know
acting in ways that involve like you
could say role modeling
rather than purely cognitive or thought
approaches whereas
plato um and this is coming from
socrates and this is why it gets to the
stoics as well
seem to think of virtues as more like
knowledge
or wisdom
modes of wisdom that we have about how
we
ought to behave the stoics actually
defined all these sub-virtues
in
that in aries didimasu's epitome of
stoic ethics as knowledge or episteme
but practical knowledge right so it's
not a complete difference between the
two of them but there's there's a
difference in emphasis you could say
here's a good one from nicole aristotle
mentioned the point of life is to
achieve happiness
and accumulation of goods what were
those categories of goods how does
virtue fit into accumulation of those
goods okay so that's a great question
um
so
we i mentioned you know goods of the
soul
which would include virtues
but also include like mental capacities
and stuff like that
goods of the body so we can talk about
like health as a good of the body
or
good looks or
um
what else does strength is is a good of
the body um and then we have external
goods and external goods are like all
the other things you you know you could
say anything else that doesn't fit into
these uh goods of the body or goods of
the soul aristotle considers to be
external goods which are from his
perspective goods so money is a good
thing
um
you know honor is a good thing
um
[Music]
what else um
connections you know friendships are
kind of tricky because they do involve
our our psyche considerably particularly
if they're the good kinds of friendships
so um how does virtue as you said figure
into the accumulation of these goods um
in a couple ways so
virtue should lead to
um
[Music]
using those goods well when we have them
now
it might also lead to accumulating those
goods like people might actually like
you more if you're a generous person or
a temperate person
um you know if they don't have to like
watch their possessions around you
because they're not worried you're going
to steal them or things like or abuse
them or things like that
um that might might conduce to that
there's no like
absolute connection like behave
virtuously you're gonna be you're gonna
have tons and tons of good stuff you're
gonna be wealthy healthy all that but
there's a sort of a
on the whole if you behave if you're a
virtuous person you're probably gonna do
okay with these things where if you're a
vicious person you're probably gonna
screw up and
you're probably not going to enjoy those
goods quite as much
because you're not really
able to conduct yourself properly
and you'll you have a good chance of
losing them
things so malcolm given the virtues must
come from a fixed and permanent
disposition of character and it appears
we develop our character through
habitual action
rather than mirror reflection how can
one begin to be virtuous if previous
virtuous actions always seem to be a
prerequisite
you do it by doing it i mean
this is this is not a
a really complicated thing
you become virtuous by behaving like a
virtuous person would and at a certain
point you cross certain thresholds
and you become virtuous and it you
should think of it less as like a switch
flipping you know or
you know
necessary and sufficient conditions or
anything like that think of it more like
a dimmer like a continuum think of it
like building your your muscles you know
when you exercise
um at a certain point you become capable
of doing certain things that you weren't
in in the past so but we're gonna
q a will already has a a question here
about context
context matters between professional and
personal life you can't just be
authentic and virtuous in the workplace
you'll get rolled over you have to have
the right combination of vicious and
virtuous what are your thoughts i think
that's wrong
i think that it first of all we can't
generalize about the workplace there is
no the workplace there are many
different kinds of workplaces
some of which are very toxic and you're
right in which if you behaved as a good
person put aside just virtuous just good
in a broad sense you're probably going
to be exploited and mistreated and you
know passed over and stuff like that
that doesn't mean that you ought to then
be vicious as a result it depends on
whether you want to
succeed whether you value
success in that sort of context and from
an aristotelian perspective they would
say
nope
that is the
way in which you
allow yourself to be corrupted
and so
you know
now this is aristotle was of course from
a fairly wealthy family had a lot of
resources it's easy to say oh you know
just be virtuous in the workplace
aristotle's not saying that you do have
to exercise some prudence but you don't
have to allow
the
antagonistic exploitative structure of
many workplaces to be a motive for you
abandoning virtue and embracing vice
[Music]
as a matter of fact
if you think about the
parts of the virtues right
at the right time with the right people
for the right reason
you might have to
modify what you're doing in the
workplace right according to what's
what's prudent to do in the workplace
but it doesn't mean that you
thereby abandon virtue you become a
coward instead of courageous you become
intemperate instead of temperate
that would be that would be a bit of a
mistake
um and we
these aren't the only um contexts we can
talk about living with neighbors we can
talk about
um
how you behave outside of the workplace
in other social situations
we can talk about
educational
things virtue would be something that
straddles all of these different
contexts you could say
so it's great that you're asking about
context because that is aristotle
doesn't say this
but we could think of virtue as context
sensitive
but not context determined
if that makes sense
uh nicole has a good question here is
worry ever good or justified it kind of
depends on what you mean by worry
so if you mean
irrational rumination that doesn't
actually do anything other than make you
feel anxious or fearful
i think most virtuous and also most you
know forms of psychotherapy would say
that's that's not something good for you
um
worry can be
helpful for thinking about like care
concern
when it's
going to be directed at improving the
situation
um or
you know
in our colloquial sense of worry there's
probably some people who don't worry
enough who don't exercise enough
attention or care or concern and we
could be like hey man you should worry
about um how much you eat right or
uh you should worry
about whether you're going to measure up
in this this situation but there we're
saying something like you should you
know you should have a rational approach
to it
um and i think that that could be okay
you know
that could make sense so it depends on
how we understand worrying
um
jose says i think that if you have a
combination of vicious and virtuous you
wouldn't really have been virtuous in
the first place sounds like the on off
switch switching personality or
character according to the context now i
mean there is something to say about
this
i i think that you're right that we we
shouldn't strive
aristotle wouldn't say there's there's a
right amount of viciousness there's no i
mean viciousness is already outside of
the mean right
that said
um
[Music]
aristotelian virtue ethics is often
pitched as if well you just behave this
way and behave this way and it kind of
ignores the fact that we as human beings
by the time we start you know say
reading the nick of mccain ethics
were you pretty screwed up
you know we might have some virtues
uh like maybe you're courageous but
you're not temperate and you're not uh
you don't have control over your anger
and um you're not truthful about
yourself right so you've got vices over
here and a virtue over here
you're you're already kind of a
combination right and then the goal is
to like hold on to the good stuff that
you've got
while
working on the problematic aspects about
yourself that you think you think need
to to be fixed or changed right
um and and i think that's that's uh
quite uh common
andy has a question here can a person
according to aristotle enjoy a shameful
or disgraceful activity not only can
they
most people do aristotle thinks that
most people are not virtuous
and that um he's also distrustful of
what we would call the many or the crowd
or the mass or the mob
you know the the the public
um he in the rhetoric he actually says
and the politics he's very pessimistic
about ordinary people and he says yeah
lots of people enjoy shameful or
disgraceful activities do they enjoy
them as fully as a person who's virtuous
enjoys
virtuous activities
no
but they can still enjoy them it's not
as if you know while they're um
i don't know what would be a good
take a sadistic person right a sadistic
person who's inflicting humiliation on
somebody else they enjoy that
um they shouldn't but they do right and
so that's that's uh
quite common
so nicole has an interesting question
here has aristotle talked about a
connection between a good sense of humor
and truthfulness
i often found people who don't joke are
often distrusting so he doesn't he he
separates these out as two different
areas of social life
that doesn't mean that we couldn't um
connect them and this goes back to that
thing that i began with right he's
giving us
outlines
and it's up to us to
fill in the parts but maybe also
to make the connections between the
different regions that were
coloring in so this might be a way in
which you
uh take these raw materials these ideas
from aristotle and then bring them
together to make sense out of your
your own experience so that's that's a
that's a good good point
um david has a good question here your
dessert example made me think can
self-control be a stepping stone to
virtue not only can it be a stepping
stone to virtue it is a stepping stone
to virtue
generally you're going to be
self-controlled you're going to exercise
mastery over self encroachia right
before you become virtuous
and
likewise lack or loss of self-control um
if you do it enough you'll probably
become vicious
right so that's why it's important that
we
we do you know pay attention to what
we're
doing and thinking and feeling
um it's not that aristotle doesn't see
any role for teaching or coaching or
reflection or journaling or any of these
sorts of things that we you know often
like to use
um
those cognitive approaches can be
helpful aristotle doesn't talk about
them much in the nick of mccann ethics
but there's no reason why we couldn't
use those or why we couldn't combine
psychotherapy with a good uh counselor
you know our therapist with uh working
on the virtues as well although they
might be a little distrustful they'll be
like why are you bringing philosophy
into this
all right andy uh has a question here
and we'll take some questions before we
end up is aristotle open to the charge
of moral indoctrination i don't think so
um if he thinks that people's emotional
responses can be conditioned and those
responses have an effect on moral
judgments than his view on being
schooled early in life is indoctrination
i would say that's not indoctrination i
would say that it you know if it's
extreme it could be indoctrination but
we're we we've got to be careful when we
use that term
um
everybody in virtue ethics
and many people outside of virtue ethics
like the utilitarians
think that our environment our childhood
all of that stuff you know has an effect
on how we think about things how we feel
about things
indoctrination is when you've got
something where it's like
very clearly laid out we're going to do
things in this way this way in this way
and usually it's a pejorative term
it would be weird to think of training a
person towards virtue
as indoctrination given the current
sense that
that we we use
and then
andy goes on this assumes moral
principles have no truth only
preferences if this charge is open is
aristotle have a defense to it yeah i
mean the defense is very commonsensical
um
moral principles are not just
empty vacuous things only preferences
that would be a different thing that we
often call emotivism uh identified as
such in the 20th century
and discussed you know at great length
by people like aj air and charles
stevenson and people like that but
um it's up to the emotivist to
prove that that's the case and i've
never seen a successful
non-question begging
[Music]
you know presentation about that um i
mean i think we could we could probably
i mean if we want to follow this moral
indoctrination line then everything is
moral indoctrination right because
it's always happening i think we've got
to be careful with that that term
ah here we go here's a question from
nicole
is it good to go a bit on the extreme
end to arrive at the mean of virtue for
some time being during habituation yeah
now it depends you still got to be
careful right you don't want to swing
all the way over into vice
and say i'm becoming virtuous as a
result but if let's say you're
struggling with anger right so you're
you're more on the vicious end like
getting angry with the wrong people
getting angrier for longer than you
should holding grudges
you know that sort of thing
and you say well i need to be at this
mean position of getting angry with the
right people for the right time
let me go over more towards this other
side
and what would that involve concretely
it doesn't it doesn't involve not
getting angry you're working on your
anger while you're angry
it would involve doing a couple things
like not expressing your anger
or not feeling yourself entitled to
express it automatically
or doing some exercises like thinking
about is my is my anger really justified
in this case you know even even doing
the just uh counting for
counting to 10
um
thing can can be helpful
um
so you know yeah
same thing with temperance
justice even you know if you're prone to
being greedy or something it might it
might fit into that
george says doesn't aristotle discuss in
book 2 that the doctrine of mean is not
absolute if so does he mean that the
mean is going to be different according
in particular
situations
um
well the he doesn't use the word
absolute to begin with and so
um
i wouldn't worry about that
so much
um
mean is going to be applied differently
in in particular situations yeah but
that doesn't mean that it becomes
let's say
up for grabs right the the contrast is
not
um
absolute versus
difference in in particular situations
they're connected together you don't
have a cookie cutter mean right you have
a mean that by its very nature has to be
applied
in complex ways
you